The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: It involves real
phenomena out there.
So we have real stuff
that happens.
So it might be an arrival
process to a bank that we're
trying to model.
This is a reality, but
this is what we have
been doing so far.
We have been playing
with models of
probabilistic phenomena.
And somehow we need to
tie the two together.
The way these are tied is that
we observe the real world and
this gives us data.
And then based on these data, we
try to come up with a model
of what exactly is going on.
For example, for an arrival
process, you might ask the
model in question, is my arrival
process Poisson or is
it something different?
If it is Poisson, what is the
rate of the arrival process?
Once you come up with your model
and you come up with the
parameters of the model, then
you can use it to make
predictions about reality or to
figure out certain hidden
things, certain hidden aspects
of reality, that you do not
observe directly, but you try
to infer what they are.
So that's where the usefulness
of the model comes in.
Now this field is of course
tremendously useful.
And it shows up pretty
much everywhere.
So we talked about the polling
examples in the
last couple of lectures.
This is, of course, a
real application.
You sample and on the basis of
the sample that you have, you
try to make some inferences
about, let's say, the
preferences in a given
population.
Let's say in the medical field,
you want to try whether
a certain drug makes a
difference or not.
So people would do medical
trials, get some results, and
then from the data somehow you
need to make sense of them and
make a decision.
Is the new drug useful
or is it not?
How do we go systematically
about the
question of this type?
A sexier, more recent topic,
there's this famous Netflix
competition where Netflix gives
you a huge table of
movies and people.
And people have rated the
movies, but not everyone has
watched all of the
movies in there.
You have some of the ratings.
For example, this person gave a
4 to that particular movie.
So you get the table that's
partially filled.
And the Netflix asks
you to make
recommendations to people.
So this means trying to guess.
This person here, how much
would they like this
particular movie?
And you can start thinking,
well, maybe this person has
given somewhat similar ratings
with another person.
And if that other person has
also seen that movie, maybe
the rating of that other
person is relevant.
But of course it's a lot more
complicated than that.
And this has been a serious
competition where people have
been using every heavy, wet
machinery that there is in
statistics, trying to
come up with good
recommendation systems.
Then the other people, of
course, are trying to analyze
financial data.
Somebody gives you the sequence
of the values, let's
say of the SMP index.
You look at something like this
and you can ask questions.
How do I model these data using
any of the models that
we have in our bag of tools?
How can I make predictions about
what's going to happen
afterwards, and so on?
On the engineering side,
anywhere where you have noise
inference comes in.
Signal processing, in
some sense, is just
an inference problem.
You observe signals that are
noisy and you try to figure
out exactly what's happening
out there or what kind of
signal has been sent.
Maybe the beginning of the field
could be traced a few
hundred years ago where people
would observe, make
astronomical observations
of the position of the
planets in the sky.
They would have some beliefs
that perhaps the orbits of
planets is an ellipse.
Or if it's a comet, maybe it's
a parabola, hyperbola, don't
know what it is.
But they would have
a model of that.
But, of course, astronomical
measurements would not be
perfectly exact.
And they would try to find the
curve that fits these data.
How do you go about choosing
this particular curve on the
base of noisy data and
try to do it in a
somewhat principled way?
OK, so questions of this
type-- clearly the
applications are all
over the place.
But how is this related
conceptually with what we have
been doing so far?
What's the relation between the
field of inference and the
field of probability
as we have been
practicing until now?
Well, mathematically speaking,
what's going to happen in the
next few lectures could be just
exercises or homework
problems in the class in based
on what we have done so far.
That means you're not going
to get any new facts about
probability theory.
Everything we're going to do
will be simple applications of
things that you already
do know.
So in some sense, statistics
and inference is just an
applied exercise
in probability.
But actually, things are
not that simple in
the following sense.
If you get a probability
problem,
there's a correct answer.
There's a correct solution.
And that correct solution
is unique.
There's no ambiguity.
The theory of probability has
clearly defined rules.
These are the axioms.
You're given some information
about probability
distributions.
You're asked to calculate
certain other things.
There's no ambiguity.
Answers are always unique.
In statistical questions, it's
no longer the case that the
question has a unique answer.
If I give you data and I ask
you what's the best way of
estimating the motion of that
planet, reasonable people can
come up with different
methods.
And reasonable people will try
to argue that's my method has
these desirable properties but
somebody else may say, here's
another method that has certain
desirable properties.
And it's not clear what
the best method is.
So it's good to have some
understanding of what the
issues are and to know at least
what is the general
class of methods that one tries
to consider, how does
one go about such problems.
So we're going to see
lots and lots of
different inference methods.
We're not going to tell
you that one is
better than the other.
But it's important to understand
what are the
concepts between those
different methods.
And finally, statistics can
be misused really badly.
That is, one can come up with
methods that you think are
sound, but in fact they're
not quite that.
I will bring some examples next
time and talk a little
more about this.
So, they want to say, you have
some data, you want to make
some inference from them, what
many people will do is to go
to Wikipedia, find a statistical
test that they
think it applies to that
situation, plug in numbers,
and present results.
Are the conclusions that they
get really justified or are
they misusing statistical
methods?
Well, too many people actually
do misuse statistics and
conclusions that people
get are often false.
So it's important to, besides
just being able to copy
statistical tests and use them,
to understand what are
the assumptions between the
different methods and what
kind of guarantees they
have, if any.
All right, so we'll try to do a
quick tour through the field
of inference in this lecture and
the next few lectures that
we have left this semester and
try to highlight at the very
high level the main concept
skills, and
techniques that come in.
Let's start with some
generalities and some general
statements.
One first statement is that
statistics or inference
problems come up in very
different guises.
And they may look as if they are
of very different forms.
Although, at some fundamental
level, the basic issues turn
out to be always pretty
much the same.
So let's look at this example.
There's an unknown signal
that's being sent.
It's sent through some medium,
and that medium just takes the
signal and amplifies it
by a certain number.
So you can think of
somebody shouting.
There's the air out there.
What you shouted will be
attenuated through the air
until it gets to a receiver.
And that receiver then observes
this, but together
with some random noise.
Here I meant S. S is the signal
that's being sent.
And what you observe is an X.
You observe X, so what kind
of inference problems
could we have here?
In some cases, you want to build
a model of the physical
phenomenon that you're
dealing with.
So for example, you don't know
the attenuation of your signal
and you try to find out what
this number is based on the
observations that you have.
So the way this is done in
engineering systems is that
you design a certain signal, you
know what it is, you shout
a particular word, and then
the receiver listens.
And based on the intensity of
the signal that they get, they
try to make a guess about A. So
you don't know A, but you
know S. And by observing X,
you get some information
about what A is.
So in this case, you're trying
to build a model of the medium
through which your signal
is propagating.
So sometimes one would call
problems of this kind, let's
say, system identification.
In a different version of an
inference problem that comes
with this picture, you've
done your modeling.
You know your A. You know the
medium through which the
signal is going, but it's
a communication system.
This person is trying
to communicate
something to that person.
So you send the signal S, but
that person receives a noisy
version of S. So that person
tries to reconstruct S based
on X.
So in both cases, we have a
linear relation between X and
the unknown quantity.
In one version, A is the unknown
and we know S. In the
other version, A is known,
and so we try to infer S.
Mathematically, you can see that
this is essentially the
same kind of problem
in both cases.
Although, the kind of practical
problem that you're
trying to solve is a
little different.
So we will not be making any
distinctions between problems
of the model building type as
opposed to models where you
try to estimate some unknown
signal and so on.
Because conceptually, the tools
that one uses for both
types of problems are
essentially the same.
OK, next a very useful
classification
of inference problems--
the unknown quantity that you're
trying to estimate
could be either a discrete
one that takes a
small number of values.
So this could be discrete
problems, such as the airplane
radar problem we encountered
back a long
time ago in this class.
So there's two possibilities--
an airplane is out there or an
airplane is not out there.
And you're trying to
make a decision
between these two options.
Or you can have other problems
would you have, let's say,
four possible options.
You don't know which one is
true, but you get data and you
try to figure out which
one is true.
In problems of these kind,
usually you want to make a
decision based on your data.
And you're interested in the
probability of making a
correct decision.
You would like that
probability to
be as high as possible.
Estimation problems are
a little different.
Here you have some continuous
quantity that's not known.
And you try to make a good
guess of that quantity.
And you would like your guess to
be as close as possible to
the true quantity.
So the polling problem
was of this type.
There was an unknown fraction
f of the population that had
some property.
And you try to estimate f as
accurately as you can.
So the distinction here is that
usually here the unknown
quantity takes on discrete
set of values.
Here the unknown quantity
takes a
continuous set of values.
Here we're interested in the
probability of error.
Here we're interested in
the size of the error.
Broadly speaking, most inference
problems fall either
in this category or
in that category.
Although, if you want to
complicate life, you can also
think or construct problems
where both of these aspects
are simultaneously present.
OK, finally since we're in
classification mode, there is
a very big, important dichotomy
into how one goes
about inference problems.
And here there's two
fundamentally different
philosophical points of view,
which is how do we model the
quantity that is unknown?
In one approach, you say there's
a certain quantity
that has a definite value.
It just happens that
they don't know it.
But it's a number.
There's nothing random
about it.
So think of trying to estimate
some physical quantity.
You're making measurements, you
try to estimate the mass
of an electron, which
is a sort of
universal physical constant.
There's nothing random
about it.
It's a fixed number.
You get data, because you have
some measuring apparatus.
And that measuring apparatus,
depending on what that results
that you get are affected by the
true mass of the electron,
but there's also some noise.
You take the data out of your
measuring apparatus and you
try to come up with
some estimate of
that quantity theta.
So this is definitely a
legitimate picture, but the
important thing in this picture
is that this theta is
written as lowercase.
And that's to make the point
that it's a real number, not a
random variable.
There's a different
philosophical approach which
says, well, anything that I
don't know I should model it
as a random variable.
Yes, I know.
The mass of the electron
is not really random.
It's a constant.
But I don't know what it is.
I have some vague sense,
perhaps, what it is perhaps
because of the experiments
that some other
people carried out.
So perhaps I have a prior
distribution on the possible
values of Theta.
And that prior distribution
doesn't mean that the nature
is random, but it's more of a
subjective description of my
subjective beliefs of where do
I think this constant number
happens to be.
So even though it's not truly
random, I model my initial
beliefs before the experiment
starts.
In terms of a prior
distribution, I view it as a
random variable.
Then I observe another related
random variable through some
measuring apparatus.
And then I use this again
to create an estimate.
So these two pictures
philosophically are very
different from each other.
Here we treat the unknown
quantities as unknown numbers.
Here we treat them as
random variables.
When we treat them as a random
variables, then we know pretty
much already what we
should be doing.
We should just use
the Bayes rule.
Based on X, find
the conditional
distribution of Theta.
And that's what we will be doing
mostly over this lecture
and the next lecture.
Now in both cases, what you end
up getting at the end is
an estimate.
But actually, that estimate is
what kind of object is it?
It's a random variable
in both cases.
Why?
Even in this case where
theta was a
constant, my data are random.
I do my data processing.
So I calculate a function
of the data, the
data are random variables.
So out here we output something
which is a function
of a random variable.
So this quantity here
will be also random.
It's affected by the noise and
the experiment that I have
been doing.
That's why these estimators
will be denoted
by uppercase Thetas.
And we will be using hats.
Hat, usually in estimation,
means
an estimate of something.
All right, so this is
the big picture.
We're going to start with
the Bayesian version.
And then the last few lectures
we're going to talk about the
non-Bayesian version or
the classical one.
By the way, I should say that
statisticians have been
debating fiercely for 100 years
whether the right way to
approach statistics is to go
the classical way or the
Bayesian way.
And there have been tides going
back and forth between
the two sides.
These days, Bayesian methods
tend to become a little more
popular for various reasons.
We're going to come back
to this later.
All right, so in Bayesian
estimation, what we got in our
hands is Bayes rule.
And if you have Bayes rule,
there's not a lot
that's left to do.
We have different forms of the
Bayes rule, depending on
whether we're dealing with
discrete data, And discrete
quantities to estimate, or
continuous data, and so on.
In the hypothesis testing
problem, the unknown quantity
Theta is discrete.
So in both cases here,
we have a P of Theta.
We obtain data, the X's.
And on the basis of the X that
we observe, we can calculate
the posterior distribution
of Theta, given the data.
So to use Bayesian inference,
what do we start with?
We start with some priors.
These are our initial
beliefs about what
Theta that might be.
That's before we do
the experiment.
We have a model of the
experimental aparatus.
And the model of the
experimental apparatus tells
us if this Theta is true, I'm
going to see X's of that kind.
If that other Theta is true, I'm
going to see X's that they
are somewhere else.
That models my apparatus.
And based on that knowledge,
once I observe I have these
two functions in my hands, we
have already seen that if you
know those two functions, you
can also calculate the
denominator here.
So all of these functions are
available, so you can compute,
you can find a formula for
this function as well.
And as soon as you observe the
data, that X's, you plug in
here the numerical value
of those X's.
And you get a function
of Theta.
And this is the posterior
distribution of Theta, given
the data that you have seen.
So you've already done
a fair number of
exercises of these kind.
So we not say more about this.
And there's a similar formula as
you know for the case where
we have continuous data.
If the X's are continuous random
variable, then the
formula is the same, except
that X's are described by
densities instead of being
described by a probability
mass functions.
OK, now if Theta is continuous,
then we're dealing
with estimation problems.
But the story is once
more the same.
You're going to use the Bayes
rule to come up with the
posterior density of Theta,
given the data
that you have observed.
Now just for the sake of the
example, let's come back to
this picture here.
Suppose that something is flying
in the air, and maybe
this is just an object in the
air close to the Earth.
So because of gravity, the
trajectory that it's going to
follow it's going to
be a parabola.
So this is the general equation
of a parabola.
Zt is the position of my
objects at time t.
But I don't know exactly
which parabola it is.
So the parameters of the
parabola are unknown
quantities.
What I can do is to go and
measure the position of my
objects at different times.
But unfortunately, my
measurements are noisy.
What I want to do is to model
the motion of my object.
So I guess in the picture, the
axis would be t going this way
and Z going this way.
And on the basis of the
data that they get,
these are my X's.
I want to figure
out the Thetas.
That is, I want to figure
out the exact
equation of this parabola.
Now if somebody gives you
probability distributions for
Theta, these would
be your priors.
So this is given.
We need the conditional
distribution of the X's given
the Thetas.
Well, we have the conditional
distribution of Z, given the
Thetas from this equation.
And then by playing with this
equation, you can also find
how is X distributed if Theta
takes a particular value.
So you do have all of the
densities that you might need.
And you can apply
the Bayes rule.
And at the end, your end result
would be a formula for
the distribution of Theta,
given to the X
that you have observed--
except for one sort of
computation, or to make things
more interesting.
Instead of these X's and Theta's
being single random
variables that we have here,
typically those X's and
Theta's will be
multi-dimensional random
variables or will correspond
to multiple ones.
So this little Theta here
actually stands for a triplet
of Theta0, Theta1, and Theta2.
And that X here stands here for
the entire sequence of X's
that we have observed.
So in reality, the object that
you're going to get at to the
end after inference is done is
a function that you plug in
the values of the data and you
get the function of the
Theta's that tells you the
relative likelihoods of
different Theta triplets.
So what I'm saying is that this
is no harder than the
problems that you have dealt
with so far, except perhaps
for the complication that's
usually in interesting
inference problems.
Your Theta's and X's are often
the vectors of random
variables instead of individual
random variables.
Now if you are to do estimation
in a case where you
have discrete data, again the
situation is no different.
We still have a Bayes rule of
the same kind, except that
densities gets replaced
by PMF's.
If X is discrete, you put a P
here instead of putting an f.
So an example of an estimation
problem with discrete data is
similar to the polling
problem.
You have a coin.
It has an unknown
parameter Theta.
This is the probability
of obtaining heads.
You flip the coin many times.
What can you tell me about
the true value of Theta?
A classical statistician, at
this point, would say, OK, I'm
going to use an estimator,
the most reasonable
one, which is this.
How many heads did they
obtain in n trials?
Divide by the total
number of trials.
This is my estimate of
the bias of my coin.
And then the classical
statistician would continue
from here and try to prove some
properties and argue that
this estimate is a good one.
For example, we have the weak
law of large numbers that
tells us that this particular
estimate converges in
probability to the
true parameter.
This is a kind of guarantee
that's useful to have.
And the classical statistician
would pretty much close the
subject in this way.
What would the Bayesian
person do differently?
The Bayesian person would start
by assuming a prior
distribution of Theta.
Instead of treating Theta as
an unknown constant, they
would say that Theta would speak
randomly or pretend that
it would speak randomly
and assume a
distribution on Theta.
So for example, if you don't
know they need anything more,
you might assume that any value
for the bias of the coin
is as likely as any other value
of the bias of the coin.
And this way so the probability
distribution
that's uniform.
Or if you have a little more
faith in the manufacturing
processes that's created that
coin, you might choose your
prior to be a distribution
that's centered around 1/2 and
sits fairly narrowly centered
around 1/2.
That would be a prior
distribution in which you say,
well, I believe that the
manufacturer tried to make my
coin to be fair.
But they often makes some
mistakes, so it's going to be,
I believe, it's approximately
1/2 but not quite.
So depending on your beliefs,
you would choose an
appropriate prior for the
distribution of Theta.
And then you would use the
Bayes rule to find the
probabilities of different
values of Theta, based on the
data that you have observed.
So no matter which version of
the Bayes rule that you use,
the end product of the Bayes
rule is going to be either a
plot of this kind or a
plot of that kind.
So what am I plotting here?
This axis is the Theta axis.
These are the possible values
of the unknown quantity that
we're trying to estimate.
In the continuous
case, theta is a
continuous random variable.
I obtain my data.
And I plot for the posterior
probability distribution after
observing my data.
And I'm plotting here the
probability density for Theta.
So this is a plot
of that density.
In the discrete case, theta can
take finitely many values
or a discrete set of values.
And for each one of those
values, I'm telling you how
likely is that the value to be
the correct one, given the
data that I have observed.
And in general, what you would
go back to your boss and
report after you've done all
your inference work would be
either a plot of this kinds
or of that kind.
So you go to your boss
who asks you, what is
the value of Theta?
And you say, well, I only
have limited data.
That I don't know what it is.
It could be this, with
so much probability.
There's probability.
OK, let's throw in some
numbers here.
There's probability 0.3 that
Theta is this value.
There's probability 0.2 that
Theta is this value, 0.1 that
it's this one, 0.1 that it's
this one, 0.2 that it's that
one, and so on.
OK, now bosses often want
simple answers.
They say, OK, you're
talking too much.
What do you think Theta is?
And now you're forced
to make a decision.
If that was the situation and
you have to make a decision,
how would you make it?
Well, I'm going to make a
decision that's most likely to
be correct.
If I make this decision,
what's going to happen?
Theta is this value with
probability 0.2, which means
there's probably 0.8 that
they make an error
if I make that guess.
If I make that decision, this
decision has probably 0.3 of
being the correct one.
So I have probably
of error 0.7.
So if you want to just maximize
the probability of
giving the correct decision, or
if you want to minimize the
probability of making an
incorrect decision, what
you're going to choose to report
is that value of Theta
for which the probability
is highest.
So in this case, I would
choose to report this
particular value, the most
likely value of Theta, given
what I have observed.
And that value is called them
maximum a posteriori
probability estimate.
It's going to be this
one in our case.
So picking the point in the
posterior PMF that has the
highest probability.
That's the reasonable
thing to do.
This is the optimal thing to do
if you want to minimize the
probability of an incorrect
inference.
And that's what people do
usually if they need to report
a single answer, if they need
to report a single decision.
How about in the estimation
context?
If that's what you know about
Theta, Theta could be around
here, but there's also some
sharp probability that it is
around here.
What's the single answer that
you would give to your boss?
One option is to use the same
philosophy and say, OK, I'm
going to find the Theta at which
this posterior density
is highest.
So I would pick this point
here and report this
particular Theta.
So this would be my Theta,
again, Theta MAP, the Theta
that has the highest a
posteriori probability, just
because it corresponds to
the peak of the density.
But in this context, the
maximum a posteriori
probability theta was the
one that was most
likely to be true.
In the continuous case, you
cannot really say that this is
the most likely value
of Theta.
In a continuous setting, any
value of Theta has zero
probability, so when we
talk about densities.
So it's not the most likely.
It's the one for which the
density, so the probabilities
of that neighborhoods,
are highest.
So the rationale for picking
this particular estimate in
the continuous case is much
less compelling than the
rationale that we had in here.
So in this case, reasonable
people might choose different
quantities to report.
And the very popular one would
be to report instead the
conditional expectation.
So I don't know quite
what Theta is.
Given the data that I have,
Theta has this distribution.
Let me just report the average
over that distribution.
Let me report to the center
of gravity of this figure.
And in this figure, the center
of gravity would probably be
somewhere around here.
And that would be a different
estimate that you
might choose to report.
So center of gravity is
something around here.
And this is a conditional
expectation of Theta, given
the data that you have.
So these are two, in some sense,
fairly reasonable ways
of choosing what to report
to your boss.
Some people might choose
to report this.
to report that.
And a priori, if there's no
compelling reason why one
would be preferable than other
one, unless you set some rules
for the game and you describe
a little more precisely what
your objectives are.
But no matter which one you
report, a single answer, a
point estimate, doesn't really
tell you the whole story.
There's a lot more information
conveyed by this posterior
distribution plot than
any single number
that you might report.
So in general, you may wish to
convince your boss that's it's
worth their time to look at the
entire plot, because that
plot sort of covers all
the possibilities.
It tells your boss most likely
we're in that range, but
there's also a distinct change
that our Theta happens to lie
in that range.
All right, now let us try to
perhaps differentiate between
these two and see under what
circumstances this one might
be the better estimate
to perform.
Better with respect to what?
We need some rules.
So we're going to throw
in some rules.
As a warm up, we're going to
deal with the problem of
making an estimation if you
had no information at all,
except for a prior
distribution.
So this is a warm up for what's
coming next, which
would be estimation that takes
into account some information.
So we have a Theta.
And because of your subjective
beliefs or models by others,
you believe that Theta is
uniformly distributed between,
let's say, 4 and 10.
You want to come up with
a point estimate.
Let's try to look
for an estimate.
Call it c, in this case.
I want to pick a number
with which to estimate
the value of Theta.
I will be interested in the size
of the error that I make.
And I really dislike large
errors, so I'm going to focus
on the square of the error
that they make.
So I pick c.
Theta that has a random value
that I don't know.
But whatever it is, once it
becomes known, it results into
a squared error between
what it is and what I
guessed that it was.
And I'm interested in making
a small air on the average,
where the average is taken
with respect to all the
possible and unknown
values of Theta.
So the problem, this is a least
squares formulation of
the problem, where we
try to minimize the
least squares errors.
How do you find the optimal c?
Well, we take that expression
and expand it.
And it is, using linearity
of expectations--
square minus 2c expected
Theta plus c squared--
that's the quantity that
we want to minimize,
with respect to c.
To do the minimization, take the
derivative with respect to
c and set it to 0.
So that differentiation gives us
from here minus 2 expected
value of Theta plus
2c is equal to 0.
And the answer that you get by
solving this equation is that
c is the expected
value of Theta.
So when you do this
optimization, you find that
the optimal estimate, the
things you should be
reporting, is the expected
value of Theta.
So in this particular example,
you would choose your estimate
c to be just the middle
of these values,
which would be 7.
OK, and in case your
boss asks you, how
good is your estimate?
How big is your error
going to be?
What you could report is the
average size of the estimation
error that you are making.
We picked our estimates to be
the expected value of Theta.
So for this particular way that
I'm choosing to do my
estimation, this is the mean
squared error that I get.
And this is a familiar
quantity.
It's just the variance
of the distribution.
So the expectation is that
best way to estimate a
quantity, if you're interested
in the mean squared error.
And the resulting mean squared
error is the variance itself.
How will this story change if
we now have data as well?
Now having data means that
we can compute posterior
distributions or conditional
distributions.
So we get transported into a new
universe where instead the
working with the original
distribution of Theta, the
prior distribution, now we work
with the condition of
distribution of Theta,
given the data
that we have observed.
Now remember our old slogan that
conditional models and
conditional probabilities are
no different than ordinary
probabilities, except that we
live now in a new universe
where the new information has
been taken into account.
So if you use that philosophy
and you're asked to minimize
the squared error but now that
you live in a new universe
where X has been fixed to
something, what would the
optimal solution be?
It would again be the
expectation of theta, but
which expectation?
It's the expectation which
applies in the new conditional
universe in which we
live right now.
So because of what we did
before, by the same
calculation, we would find that
the optimal estimates is
the expected value of X of
Theta, but the optimal
estimate that takes
into account the
information that we have.
So the conclusion, once you get
your data, if you want to
minimize the mean squared error,
you should just report
the conditional estimation of
this unknown quantity based on
the data that you have.
So the picture here is that
Theta is unknown.
You have your apparatus that
creates measurements.
So this creates an X. You take
an X, and here you have a box
that does calculations.
It does calculations and it
spits out the conditional
expectation of Theta, given the
particular data that you
have observed.
And what we have done in this
class so far is, to some
extent, developing the
computational tools and skills
to do with this particular
calculation--
how to calculate the posterior
density for Theta and how to
calculate expectations,
conditional expectations.
So in principle, we know
how to do this.
In principle, we can program a
computer to take the data and
to spit out condition
expectations.
Somebody who doesn't think like
us might instead design a
calculating machine that does
something differently and
produces some other estimate.
So we went through this argument
and we decided to
program our computer to
calculate conditional
expectations.
Somebody else came up with some
other crazy idea for how
to estimate the random
variable.
They came up with some function
g and the programmed
it, and they designed a machine
that estimates Theta's
by outputting a certain
g of X.
That could be an alternative
estimator.
Which one is better?
Well, we convinced ourselves
that this is the optimal one
in a universe where we have
fixed the particular
value of the data.
So what we have proved so far
is a relation of this kind.
In this conditional universe,
the mean squared
error that I get--
I'm the one who's using
this estimator--
is less than or equal than the
mean squared error that this
person will get, the person
who uses that estimator.
For any particular value of
the data, I'm going to do
better than the other person.
Now the data themselves
are random.
If I average over all possible
values of the data, I should
still be better off.
If I'm better off for any
possible value X, then I
should be better off on the
average over all possible
values of X.
So let us average both sides of
this quantity with respect
to the probability distribution
of X. If you want
to do it formally, you can write
this inequality between
numbers as an inequality between
random variables.
And it tells that no matter
what that random variable
turns out to be, this quantity
is better than that quantity.
Take expectations of both
sides, and you get this
inequality between expectations
overall.
And this last inequality tells
me that the person who's using
this estimator who produces
estimates according to this
machine will have a mean squared
estimation error
that's less than or equal to
the estimation error that's
produced by the other person.
In a few words, the conditional
expectation
estimator is the optimal
estimator.
It's the ultimate estimating
machine.
That's how you should solve
estimation problems and report
a single value.
If you're forced to report a
single value and if you're
interested in estimation
errors.
OK, while we could have told you
that story, of course, a
month or two ago, this is really
about interpretation --
about realizing that conditional
expectations have
a very nice property.
But other than that, any
probabilistic skills that come
into this business are just the
probabilistic skills of
being able to calculate
conditional expectations,
which you already
know how to do.
So conclusion, all of optimal
Bayesian estimation just means
calculating and reporting
conditional expectations.
Well, if the world were that
simple, then statisticians
wouldn't be able to find jobs
if life is that simple.
So real life is not
that simple.
There are complications.
And that perhaps makes their
life a little more
interesting.
OK, one complication is that we
would deal with the vectors
instead of just single
random variables.
I use the notation here
as if X was a
single random variable.
In real life, you get
several data.
Does our story change?
Not really, same argument--
given all the data that you
have observed, you should
still report the conditional
expectation of Theta.
But what kind of work does it
take in order to report this
conditional expectation?
One issue is that you need to
cook up a plausible prior
distribution for Theta.
How do you do that?
In a given application , this
is a bit of a judgment call,
what prior would you
be working with.
And there's a certain
skill there of not
making silly choices.
A more pragmatic, practical
issue is that this is a
formula that's extremely nice
and compact and simple that
you can write with
minimal ink.
But the behind it there could
be hidden a huge amount of
calculation.
So doing any sort of
calculations that involve
multiple random variables really
involves calculating
multi-dimensional integrals.
And the multi-dimensional
integrals are hard to compute.
So implementing actually this
calculating machine here may
not be easy, might be
complicated computationally.
It's also complicated in terms
of not being able to derive
intuition about it.
So perhaps you might want to
have a simpler version, a
simpler alternative to this
formula that's easier to work
with and easier to calculate.
We will be talking about
one such simpler
alternative next time.
So again, to conclude, at
the high level, Bayesian
estimation is very, very simple,
given that you have
mastered everything that
has happened in
this course so far.
There are certain practical
issues and it's also good to
be familiar with the concepts
and the issues that in
general, you would prefer to
report that complete posterior
distribution.
But if you're forced to report a
point estimate, then there's
a number of reasonable
ways to do it.
And perhaps the most reasonable
one is to just the
report the conditional
expectation itself.